my talk is entitled cognitive bias a
reflection in a path forward and before
I start I want to give you guys a little
bit of history or a little bit of
knowledge of why I called this talk this
this is my first time going the strange
loop but I've heard about it since this
exception and what I knew is that Alex
taught me to speak about something that
wasn't technical so I said I can't just
say what I'm going to talk about I have
to make up a crazy smart topic so people
would actually think that I'm going to
bring something new to the table so a
reflection in a path forward sounds
pretty smart right so let me show you
how this talk is going to progress
I like Twitter it's another persona it's
not the real Brian
it's the almost real Brian it's the
Brian that could be the brain that might
be the barn that should be but something
happened to me today on Twitter and I
want to share with you I think I've won
Twitter today I mean literally so
if you need investment advice come speak
to me afterwards all right
so on to the real come home to the real
stuff I'll tell you why I do these
little warmups
last time I went to dinner and we
wouldn't Ferguson went down to Ferguson
and you know you watched some TV but
while I was there and eating and then we
drove through where everything happened
I started feeling a little weird and
come to find out hey guess what Brian
that's a panic attack you know about
those and I was with friends and I
actually like started cramping up in the
car and I just said I have to get out I
have to get out I have to get out and
when you if you know you're not anxiety
once you have a panic attack go into the
next couple of days you're a little
jittery so I you know that was my little
warmup they'll take that is what the
topics gonna actually be about there are
some meeting here so that's where I'm
coming from so if I start shaking it's
not part of the show someone anyone here
I know we're all actually I'm gonna die
it's all techies in here so it's alright
so let's get into this I'm gonna guess
you're a programmer or write software or
do something along the lines of making
tech anywhere who doesn't do that this
is awesome Oh see so the cool thing
about this this talk has no software in
it so it doesn't matter I'm just gonna
talk to you as if you are a programmer
so are you really like programmers that
might be you I have rabies
anyone else here I have our groupies I
mean nothing like the band sense but do
you know I have a I have a gang of
followers and they really like so I
don't talk about operating systems and
talk about bias everyone here has their
favorite operating system any plan 9 I
mean I'm a huge fan of what plan 9 could
have been you know I'm looking up I
can't see a lot of laptops here but I'm
sure there's some Mac users here I'm
sure there are some Windows users here
I'm sure there are some some Linux users
here are there any FreeBSD users here
yes you know this is actually your
section of the talk because
you my friend I know you'd like perform
a computing because we know that we know
that when it comes push come to shove
if you throw a my sequel database or
Postgres database on three bsd and same
hardware it may or may not be faster I'm
gonna it's not don't you're ruining the
story here I'm talking about bias but
there are there are I actually I was
kidding but there are parts of FreeBSD
there are faster than what Linux is so
and what I'm trying to get at is we like
good driver support so maybe we don't
use FreeBSD in a matter of fact if you
like good driver support why would you
use Linux why don't you use something
like Windows because drivers typically
work better in Windows but why why do we
use what we use do we like the copyleft
I know there's some copyleft fans in
here I work with some copyleft people
and they're they're really really into
it so whether it's LGPL GPL 2 MP lb 2
they really they're really into this but
you know some of us like our software 3
literally free free free free to do
whatever you want with so why did Linux
be FreeBSD and the question is I mean
really why and I can tell you right now
I don't have an answer but what I'm
saying is that certain biases in the
late 90s actually led people more into
the Linux camp than into the FreeBSD
camp because I swear to God in 1993 I
said FreeBSD is going to be it and I
learned all about ports and I learned
about compiling my kernels and getting
this and then this thing called Linux
came along and my soundcloud driver
didn't work so I learned I learned how
Linux kernel drivers worked back in then
this is this is really really early days
I mean like like all the way up before
one up until one before one - I'm gonna
I'm gonna write these Linux kernel
drivers but I was always wondering why
did we not use FreeBSD and what I
couldn't find out is that there is no
real answer of why either one or either
other other one lost what it is is that
certain biases kept us always looking in
the same direction so what I'm here
today is talk about thinking about bias
and you know I have to
give you disclaimer I am NOT a scientist
in psychology I cannot tell you about
cognitive bias theory
I am a pungent on Twitter and I know
what the two words mean separately so
we're gonna put them together today and
we're going to we're going to have a
discussion about biases and you might
and other people you might have
approached this from conformational
therm
see it's hard work for me to say
confirmation bias and how we are all
implicitly biased but I want to talk
about biases in a different way this
right now we can all agree that we
either like or dislike certain texts and
hopefully no one actually gets their
feelings hurt about it so what's your
favorite programming we'll just scream
it out basic Raz
and what and what I did not hear was
everyone say the same thing everybody
has their own preferences and and you
know your preferences come from who
taught you how to development who your
idols were in developing the the school
you went to depending on the school you
went to so if you want to CMU what
language do you think that you've
learned the best you want to see them
use any CMU grads here that's right ml
but let's say if you went to Stanford
what did you learn and for or for those
of us playing at home I've heard nothing
so Stanford teaches nothing that's okay
you know I'm not here to pass judgment
I'm just here to make the slides move
forward so you know personally I like
closure but I cannot use it to make
money because I I'm not an old school
hacker but I'm actually a lot older than
I look and I did start with Common Lisp
way back in the day and I just never was
able to be productive because I didn't
get productive work when I was learning
it I learned it as a toy so as I saw the
lists and the schemes and and when
closure came along I couldn't be serious
about it and those were my biases and
you notice what I'm saying that it's not
that it was good or it was bad it's just
what I saw is my preference it's what I
it was some people around me actually
the funny thing is I didn't grow up with
any developers I was the
was that nerdy guy who wrote software I
you know what it worked out believe it
or not that so I wasn't when I was
growing up there was no one that I could
actually debate on you know something
that's c99 wow that's much better than
this Pascal is coming out and it's going
to actually be past gallon long term or
you know that I'm from DC area and
there's actually a lot of ADA developers
you know ADA is definitely going to take
off in the rest of the world but you
know I couldn't have that conversation
except for me and myself so I might be
talking to myself right now I'm bringing
up memories from being a kid but back to
what I was talking about why doesn't
everyone like closure and you know what
you can say it or not it doesn't matter
why it everyone doesn't like closure you
like closure and as long as as long as
you are productive in closure it's all
good so I saw this tweet yesterday and
you know I actually almost I hope this
person said I'm not doing this to
embarrass or call this person out what
I'm actually saying is that even on
Twitter we say things that we think are
innocuous but come on for me the most
relaxing thing about strange loop nobody
talks about Ruby I'm not gonna calling
you names out but I can look out in this
crowd and I see actually some very
prominent rubyist in this room people
who have done really who have done great
things at Ruby people have done things
with Ruby core now so at the point where
you are where you are writing things on
Ruby core I don't care if you agree if
it's good or bad are you the same level
of developer if somebody who started
hacking in closure four weeks ago and
now knows and you know they know about
their cutters and whatever else probably
not so we don't talk about languages and
this is my response I actually I had it
I think I had a great response to this
and I always like to say I've to
approach this with a little bit of
pragmatism you know I don't look at
myself I wrote Ruby for a long time for
money I wrote C for a long time for
money I wrote C++ for money but guess
what at the end of the day I'm a
software developer I write software for
money I don't care
that sounds bad but the whole point is
is that we don't get what we should not
get lost in the dogma of weaken champ is
I'm championing your favorite high
school sports team at the end of the day
you're just in high school and it
doesn't really matter but go team but
don't get me wrong I'm actually a huge
fan of sports at all the levels but you
know when I come to st. Louis I don't
say you know those Cardinals y'all suck
I don't say that whatever you lose the
games they shoot off fireworks because
they do come to find out I don't say
anything like that it's you know it's
all good
different strokes for different folks so
so now that I've warmed you up a little
bit
movers Brian laughs and I am a software
developer evangelist strategy type
person at digitalocean that's me last
week when I was on to it so what I do
what I like to do is I want to talk
about weird and different things I've
done talks on neural networks I've been
talked to machine learning and now I'm
doing the talk I don't even know what
this talks about yet but we're getting
into it and then a couple weeks ago I'm
instead of talk on DevOps and how to
build great immutable stacks but what I
find is that I just like to share all
these good ideas with all these smart
people so I get all the feedback that to
make myself better so really what you're
what you're actually participating in is
my selfish experiment to be better than
all of you
so and either say that in this talk I do
not represent digitalocean because I'm
not talking about technology but they
did put a lot of money into getting me
here I took some of Alex's money but I'm
on a much longer trip so digitalocean is
sponsoring my trip and we do good things
look at us up on Twitter and that's all
I'm gonna say about digital ocean
so moving on into the harder parts of
this talk what is a software developer
look like
so I've already decided I mean we've
already decided collectively that all of
us except for this fine lady up front
are software developers and so but I
want to talk to you what I think a
software developer looks like this is
Kelsey Hightower he actually spoke on
this stage yesterday afternoon or
yesterday morning this is a friend of
mine Malcolm Preston soft you know this
is Wes Felton this is guy this is Jackie
I seen a New York guy this is Eric
Carlson and I happen to work with Eric
but one thing that on points I'm trying
to prove is that you know not everybody
I showed you was a software developer
do you know what's when it wasn't which
one of those guys was not a software
developer no clue because guess what you
can't look at somebody and tell if they
write software and come to find out the
guy les Felton is not this person right
here you might not know who he is but if
you are into any type of rap music or
R&B he goes by the name of 9th wonder
this guy right here you might if you
listen to R&B he goes by the name of
Raheem DeVaughn a very very popular
platinum selling artist and together
these two guys this guy is actually a
good friend of mine they have a group
called crossroads out of DC but the
thing is is that you didn't know he was
some music you know he was a musician a
rapper or singer by looking at him
because you know what it's only a
picture and the point that I'm trying to
make is we need
me up here I'm only a person and what
one of our writing software I'm a
developer and when all of you are
writing software you're developers but
when I look at you unless you where I'm
gonna developer t-shirt I do not know
that you're a developer so this is the
hardest section of my talk and I really
I don't want to alienate anybody but I
can look around I can actually see
everybody in the room and there's not a
lot of black guys in here and the reason
I pick on black guys and this is
actually it's actually so simple if I
click on black guys I am one I can talk
about I can talk about the struggles of
black guys in tech I can't serve I can't
talk about the struggles of women in
tech I can't even talk about the
struggles of black women in tech this
guess what I'm not a woman but for this
point I can talk about at least my
struggles in tech so being black in tech
how is it that's alright you know for me
it that is it's alright but I'll tell
you why it's alright because when I was
young middle school age my father was in
the army and he got access to a lot of
things and one thing he got access to
that he didn't really think about was
the C programming manuals from the Army
and he brought him home and he's like
you're gonna learn this then let me tell
you why because funny thing now I am 6
foot 2 inches tall but I grew six inches
between my freshman between between and
I was about 18 and 20 I was actually not
very tall and I wasn't very fast I
couldn't jump very high and I was very
small so football lacrosse track and
field basketball soccer those were those
are even guess what I'm allergic to
everything outside so and that wasn't
happening so my father being a great man
that he is saying well this guy's gonna
do something how about computers you can
do them inside
I learned I learned because there really
was no other option I didn't but you
know my I didn't have the option and I
didn't have this thing where my father
was I hear this story a lot where people
all right I'm intact my father worked at
IBM or you know my mother did this and
this while I was growing up I didn't see
that matter of fact everybody my mom is
a isn't clerical my father is he's
amazing I should tell you about him some
time but he never done things computers
and matter of fact my brother's to this
day they both are blue-collar workers
and they don't even want to be in tech
so but I'm in tech and I want to see
more people who look like me in tech but
you know we are we're working on it but
it's not all good so everyone loves
anecdote and I heard this anecdote and
they're not gonna in tribute to the
person I heard it from but I think it's
actually encapsulate the best way of
telling of everyone of how it feels to
be black in tech yeah now listen this is
this is actually it's a really short
story so I'm gonna tell you a secret
about people in tech most development
team are full of [ __ ] and just
here's the reason why you're smart you
know you're smart and you grew up in a
very smart bubble you were probably the
smartest person in your school but as
you become and you and you work with
others you realize that your smartest is
budding up with someone else is smart
and now you have to prove you're smarter
than them and then and then and then
guess what now it's just like womp womp
womp womp I'm better than you I'm better
than you I'm better than you and that's
cool when everybody looks the same now
that's what what happens when I come
into the room and that happens that
starts happening to me the first thing
I'm going to think is whatever you
whenever you're kind of being a jerk to
me oh wait a second it's because of my
color and then I go oh it's not a waste
thing but guess what Society has told me
that it's a race thing things happen to
people who look like me so guess what no
matter what you say no matter how you
feel you're probably not even a racist
I'm not even putting that on you it
looks like it's racism to me and guess
what in that and when that happens I
take a step back not here it's gonna
fall that
I'm also doing something else a little
different I've watched a few talks in
this room when no one's actually walked
across the stage or settlement seat so I
might do all of these things and that's
actually why my slides upright because
I'm brown and I realize I put white
slides here you would not be able to see
me because for camera yes so it's funny
I've been black for 39 years I know what
and what not to do so um so so that's my
anecdote so you realize what I'm saying
it's not that you're being racist but to
someone who doesn't look like you they
don't quite understand why you're acting
that way so there's a simple solution to
all this you know just stop being a jerk
but that might be too simple so a lot of
things people like to ask me hey Brian
why don't they were blacks in tech hey
you know I always say I don't know I
know why I'm in tech I know why I know
why some of you all are intact but we
can't just blankly we can't just have
this question that put me put out there
so why aren't there more blacks in tech
I can give you a whole bunch of reasons
why I think realize that slavery ended
in 1860s and then we had Jim Crow
basically up to the 1960s and even past
Jim Crow we were even at the end of
World War two we had issues where GIS
were coming home actually this is a good
story we have end of World War two we
had GIS coming home from from war and we
had the GI Bill and what they people did
the GI Bill some with the college Tim
bought houses and you know even the
black soldiers were able to get this but
here's the black people were not able to
do hi actually being a federal agency
could not discriminate but what
neighborhood covenants can discriminate
so what they would do is they would
write in their covenants that if you if
you sold a house to a black person we
would we would actually remove some the
funding from this neighborhood so guess
what happens white people can get houses
and have institutional wealth and and
generational wealth but black people
could not and all they could do they can
only live in these sections and then
they can only afford they can only live
in these parts of the cities that's why
you have black parts of cities because
guess what it's not because they all
wanted to live together they wanted to
live where all the good
and the good work was but guess what
they could not so understand that those
pipelines to the 70s that's by the time
I was born and now think about it if you
have copy neighborhoods you have crappy
schools and you and you have parents you
have broken families and what happens is
if you have broken families the kids at
home are not getting that that push that
they need to do better in life they're
getting that push it says we need to eat
if you listen to Abby's talk yesterday
she said she worked 30 hours as a
teenager that kills me but so if you
don't if you don't know what you can't
do if you don't know what you can do you
will not be able to do it it's simple
it's like if you tell yourself that you
will not be able to do something of
course you won't so that's not an answer
but that's a lot of the reasons and
guess what there are there are black men
in tech and you know this is a
generational problem it's not a pipeline
problem please do not go back to your
work and figure out how do we get more
blacks in tech does not work that way
but as the society gets better and
there's more opportunities afforded to
people who who might not have had it we
will have a more diverse makeup or we
can just wait because right now I'm
children in elementary school it's
actually less than 50% white so the
world is actually trying to get browner
I mean some of us are trying to stop it
but the world is going to get browner so
just by attrition we'll make it so I've
gone 20 minutes and I have like 60 more
slides so I put this in here because I
wasn't sure with and what the crowd was
going to be like so why is PHP so
popular I don't know let's move on
so path third so I actually just in my
talk I'm in my in my title to put her
path forward and I was thinking about
this what's the path forward I'm gonna
give you a solution or I think I'm gonna
give you a solution and it's not what
you think so
you know Apple always has an another
thing so I'm actually gonna change iMac
I'm not gonna change the sentiment of
the talk and I'm gonna change the focus
of the talk and I want to talk about
something else right now for all the
Americans in here for everyone in here
this is this is Harrison Ford he's
Indiana Jones my childhood hero and he
isn't gonna be the focus of the rest of
the talk so thinking about how do we get
more black men in tech I always want to
think why are we asking that question we
shouldn't think of how to get more
people into something we should ask why
are they aren't fair because once you
start saying how we'll start changing
the rules will invent things like
affirmative action and I'll tell you
what just as a sidebar affirmative
action sucks but that's what the bad
part about affirmative action is it
worked it actually got people in places
where they would not have been but I
don't want to be in a place because of
my skin color I want to be a place
because of my aptitude but so let's talk
about housing wise so how is good how's
great um you want to know how to be
something you want to know how to write
software you want to know how to build
these complex distributed systems
knowing how to do it is good but yeah so
how do we develop software there's a lot
of people in here I'm actually seeing a
lot of faces there's a lot of smart
people in here who know how to build a
lot of disparate systems you also know
how to to write your code but why do you
use Emacs you ever thought about that
I mean besides all the dogma of it's
better than them which is actually not
true I'm just giving you a benefit of
the doubt
and you thought why you use emacs is it
because that crazy Lisp in there is is a
great way to configure your editor
environment because it thinks like you
listen because you can actually have
more than one size font if you don't use
a terminal and actually I think that's
the reason why I use it I think that's
pretty cool but why do you see max why
do you use vim because it's better than
everything else of course but you don't
use it for dem scripts of course unless
you're Tim Pope then you might use it
for vem script but you don't use it for
dem script um why do you use sublime
text I don't know I don't use the boring
text so I don't know why do you use it
but if you thought why do I actually use
the editor that I use
why do you intelligence because you're
writing Java that's easy
super super simple I'm sorry that was a
gimme why do you test your software and
actually this is my ode to gaben art why
do you mean to test your software when
you use static types I'm gonna sound
silly your type system is gonna tell you
if your software is valid right that
makes sense that's chrome youlet right
but of course this is not what I mean
but but I don't want to talk about is
how is how versus why and software
development like I was talking before
earlier I said before earlier how do we
hire a more diverse workforce this is
not what we should be talking about we
should be talking about why we do not
have a diverse workforce and except that
guess what there are problems out there
that we cannot solve I know that in
software we've been very good about
solving problems but there's there are
certain things in the world that we can
make better without solving them so even
though this is
actually you're wrong it was HTTP 1-1
it's been deprecated so now they decided
that HTTP 1-1 was so awesome we're gonna
put it in eight RFC's but actually going
that was a trick question
so basically and this is more trolling
on there's no real be at this conference
yeah this is some rails rails
controllers and I and actually I
actually did this little section before
and I know in a ruby talk and I went I
went down the path myself do you know
this RFC ISM people were like and I said
well what do you do for a living and
people are like well we write rails and
I said and you know about it should if
he gets and posts and puts and delete
some options ahead and they said yeah
and I said well how do you know about
that
well we found on the internet and I said
well have you read the documentation
well yes I said well have you heard of
have you heard of the RFC they said yes
I said I don't believe you because guess
what the RFC actually displays
everything you're doing if you're not
reading the RFC's or papers how do you
really know it's all if it's like
playing telephone when you play
telephone they talk to the first person
and then the message changes a little
bit and by the time you get to the tenth
person the message is broken you are the
11th person to think about that so I'm
back to this one like I said I wanted to
show the proof it is it has been
superseded a couple of times but wow
I've really was into this
yeah yeah I'm I'm all over the place so
so realize what I'm doing here
I am telling you little anecdotes in
lieu of giving you technical content to
try to make you think about just biases
in general I'm not asking you to accept
anything new I'm asking you to change
your ways and I really want you to look
at the man in the mirror sorry sorry
sorry I tried but that's what I was
talking about whatever I'm really trying
to get you to just think about things
from look there is your point of view
and your point of view may be correct
but the the the crazy thing about
correctness in the real world is it's
not black and white you can be correct I
can say is this cup half empty or is it
half full and I'm still correct and then
some nerds going to say well no it's
full of h2o at the bottom and the
nitrogen and oxygen at the top and then
I'm gonna say well no that's actually
dumb is you know what I'm talking about
here invited by by bringing us up in
these kinds of ways I'm just trying to
make you think that when you think
you're correct
you're only correct in that situation
where you are are you correct in
situation for the person sitting next to
you how can you help the person sitting
next to you actually feel better about
without working environment how can you
make that how can you make the person
that you haven't even met yet feel
better about their working environment
and I don't know but something to think
about
so how did we get more women in software
development how do we get more
minorities in software development this
is a hot button for me this word is the
fetus word please stop using it it's the
fetus by calling us minorities you've
already signified that we are less and
guess what we're not less
we're equally is bad awful great amazing
as everyone else so people are
suggesting under-represented I don't
know it's a lot of syllables
so earlier I saw a talk where someone
mentioned that they were replacing
millenials with words like what snakes
whenever you see minorities just think
awesomeness it'll help it'll help so how
do we get more of these people in
software development I don't know but I
do know this and I'll read this out loud
says wishing for minorities and women to
attend your tech conference it's like
having a party and inviting all dudes
and it'll take a second and you'll
realize that what I'm saying is that if
you have a conference or an event or a
workplace and you're saying how do we
get more women in here you've already
lost you were asking the wrong question
why do they not why are they not there
that's the question you should answer
and you know the answer is the answers
the answer the two answers are having
more women and awesome people in your
leadership I mean that will go as far
higher hiring a woman to be your CTO
will actually change the way you do
business because guess what women are
wired differently than men and it's not
a race thing it's just women are wired
differently than men they have babies
they have to be amazing so how this is
why in the real world and like I said
stream of amazing coming at you here so
there's no such thing as bad code unless
it's bad code of course so do you want
to be a better software developer you
need to cook like Indiana Jones I did
say this was the Indiana Jones section
so what does that mean you get a whip
you go treasure-hunting
you should always be looking for for the
jeans in the rough I don't I don't know
what that means but she'll know what it
means there's jewels in your codebase
there's jewels on the internet there are
no jewels on Hacker News unless you read
it like I do which is you go through the
comments first you sort them or you get
something to sort them and you read the
first sentence of the first comment if
it's negative you just stop reading it's
90 more articles not even worth it but
if it is then you can then you can go
read the article then be afraid to throw
a punch
seriously things are messed up for a lot
of people right now so if you have
to go to bat for someone or yourself you
should not be afraid to do that a whip
is useful I actually do not have an
anecdote for this I just think a whip is
useful it belongs in a museum I will say
that about your code realize the code
that you wrote yesterday is legacy and
if you need to figure out it's one thing
or two things you need to figure out
that you are a person your code is this
object that lives and bits on your
system you are not your code so if
someone talks about your code they are
not talking about you
so they get upset like you say hey Brian
your code sucks you know I'm gonna say
yeah whatever you know I had to poop or
something and you know what I'm fine
with that because I've been pooping for
39 years
realize that you add not your code and
actually that's that's actually a
defense mechanism that I've learned is
the black developer is that you have to
develop a thick skin so sometimes people
talk to me they're like Brian do you
remember me and I'm like no usually it's
not because I don't it's just because
I'm like I'm a little tense right now
because you know it's a weird situation
for me for remember your code is an
artifact you can you can you can
treasure it or most likely you can just
get rid of it and rewrite it or make it
better I'm not saying rewrite your whole
project so I'm just talking about these
little bits and I hate snakes
so I told you this is crazy
so how do we succeed we're a donut idea
we fail miserably we pivot we got that
dot and we profit I don't understand
that so let's talk about how versus why
so how is always less than Y and Y is
always greater than how and I'm gonna
leave you with an anecdote and some
quotes and then I'm gonna say thank you
and then we're gonna clap and then we're
gonna go to break more success more
money so in business they tell us more
money equals more success right that's
your company and successful if it makes
more money and I hope I mean I looked at
the code of conduct and I actually was
scared because I want to talk about
unicorns because being unicorn is very
very important these days
we want more unicorn
unicorns and for those of you that for
those of you who do not know the
unicorns are there are these businesses
or startups who are worth two billion
dollars not you have made a billion
dollars but who are worth a billion
dollars and I and and I apologize for
the unicorn porn so I did think about
that but I just wanted to make sure that
I didn't offend anybody with unicorns
I'm not unicorn issed right back to my
story so understanding builds trust if
you understand why I'm coming from you
are more likely to trust me we can agree
with that so and then also more trust
equals more speed because I trust you
and I trust my mechanisms when I trust
my processes I will move faster we know
this is dev teams get better they're
more diverse and they and they have
great ways of working together where
they actually end up shipping code
better faster cheaper right so more
understanding should equal more speed
and if more speed should equal more
money so understanding why because when
you understand why you're building that
trust cuz you actually understand where
you're coming from you should have more
money and this this is my slide to
satisfy anyone who's in charge of
budgets you can take this back to your
your your companies and you can run with
this I'll get you for free so in
conclusion I love being able to create
software for living by your hand if you
love being able to create software for a
living we are in a very unique position
where we actually get to do our hobby
for some of us not all of us as a job
and they pay us way more money than
sometimes I think they should to do this
I'm not saying that I will take any less
money to do this
I'm saying that you know and I'll say my
brother's an electrician he does not
make a lot of money but his job is
legitimately dangerous a couple weeks
ago he actually was in an explosion
third-degree burns up here here in his
face he's in hospital for almost a week
and I will tell you he does not make a
lot of money we we literally make
multipliers most people in this room
make multipliers of what he's making and
he does was generally dangerous work and
we are lucky lucky people let's act like
it so how is good why is great and I
will leave you with a couple quotes from
famous people of our time arthur c
clarke says the only way to discover the
limits of the possible is to go beyond
them answer the impossible fair i agree
with that but another great poet said
difficult takes a day impossible takes a
week this is my doppelganger jay-z wink
wink and then and then another famous
poet says today was a good day and my
extra point was like I was saying is I'm
here to lower your defenses about biases
I'm up here talking about some crazy
topics that you know are very hard for
some of us to actually comprehend but
I'm putting it to you away that if we
don't take ourselves so lightly we can
actually move forward nothing that's
really the goal here is that we take
ourselves too seriously and we should
realize that people who are not like us
actually can help us in ultimately an
end of the day we all really like the
same thing so with that I'm Bren Lyles
and thank you for attending my talk my
non-technical talk is strange lib Wow
and you've been great